[Music]
you paint miniatures you paint your
figures figure out miniature figurines
yeah okay 94 millimeter scale really
small ones okay and and you what are
they what kind of a little comic actor
yeah they're like futuristic and then
there's there's ones from you know
fantasy from the past
they're called war hammer okay yeah well
here's my question do you yeah those are
the two saddest woes I and it's a guy
holding one that's something called war
hammer
yeah it's called war hammer you should
be like yeah
why do you I'm not just curious like
okay let's say you're dating do you are
you upfront about the miniature
figurines do you come out with that
right away yeah it's like it's like the
first thing I say I'm like I like wanna
come back my ah see my miniature
[Applause]
because if they don't like my miniature
isn't it's not going yeah yeah trust me
know exactly what you're talking about
about divergent this is the first of
three films yeah and we have a clip here
from the movie first of all will you at
all worried about signing up for
divergent because if for any reason you
didn't like the experience on the first
one you're locked in for a long time
yeah yeah you know and look I you know
listen I would probably lie to you if it
was bad and tell you it was good right
um but it was actually really good right
the first one now I can't tell no I've
heard really good things about it
actually a really good movie so we're
excited now I'm really hyper to the next
to you know well we have a clip here
from divergent and I think this is where
your sister comes to see you played by
shailene woodley and and she is trying
to get some kind of advice from you and
let's take a look at this scene from
divergent interest
what are you doing here I'm in trouble
what happened I'm not gonna make it
Thomas
I don't fit in there you have to fend in
there I can't
and I'm I'm just I'm not like them
and who is that crazy maybe I can go
back to abnegation
you can't go back I know they're never
gonna let you do that I think you should
go opens in theaters next Friday Ansel
really cooled to me excellent Rach
you're great
yeah really fun talking